hello beautiful people how is it going sorry for my voice today i'm a little bit sick
i don't feel good but we don't care we need to go live we don't care guys
today i open my chart and the only thing i saw is this
without the rebound i saw this this is nasdaq today
crazy like not even opening the session because it started to collapse before can you see my screen
properly guys let me know so in days like this i can play the flip account but i don't touch the main
account the multi-million account because it's usually we will chart anyway guys we will chart
anyway but usually what you see is profit release and then you start like this for hours and hours
and hours now before i go to chart i want to tell you something first of all i'm proud of you i saw
crazy numbers crazy statistics in the um in the medal awards okay crazy statistic in the medal awards
second of all we have the skill now there is someone that took the short
data feed is having a slight delay let me check i don't think so let me check
no my data feed is working fine
my data feed is working fine guys it's real time there is no you can check
this is the candle of 30 432 european times it's live
an hour ago guys i noticed that recently big speed specifically
a little bit less rhythmic are having data issue under release of high
high moving news okay and i think it's because they are processing huge amount of data for
a huge amount of users and the data gets delayed from one or two seconds you know when i experienced this
i experienced this yesterday in the fomc i saw i saw the delay you see also luca is having a little bit
of delay okay now uh before going directly to the chart let me put this one here
i want to give a quick read
i have people
so publishing here something that in two weeks not even two weeks this is the second week
i was thinking was impossible that is for example claudio italian claudio ianello that 12 minutes ago
publish a total execution of 13 trades all green like 100 we rate it took 13 take profit and if you
see the metric the skew the winning trades on average 500 dollars and the losing trade it's 140
crazy numbers i saw the track record of jonas some of you and as you know as i promise after this live
we uh go out with the um battlefield chat okay that is not a video game but the battlefield child
chat is where i take the best people in the uh normal medal awards and i put them with uh the
possibility to speak in the in the battlefield chat okay now i think i have a really smart community
okay i think i have a smart community so what i would like to do is the following instead of restricting
people that are not yet at crazy profitability level or sustainable level of profits i think the
community is smart enough to not publish if you are not having results guys can you avoid for me
doing the work of blocking someone letting someone else talk and be honest and say look i am still
i have still problem i will not publish otherwise i can confuse other people okay so you have a team of
professional that will publish for you and you can compare this and then you can you can maybe
uh see leonardo did eight thousand and eight hundred dollars today on the short amazing okay this is
easier i think it's easier without yeah you can so for the question nobody i will do another
uh another section and for the other section it will be uh the uh q and a between the community
but the battlefield chat is to give you additional value of the community and i would like to have
people that talk that are profitable are people that are constant okay then of course we have drawdown
there are people that will have one month of drawdown people that will have two months of drawdowns one
one week is part of the game okay the important stuff is on the long run from the law we are talking
about quarters we are talking about years it's normal to have the bad day it's not guys but look at this
look at this 16 000 on the short
it's disgusting damien at the third lesson you should at least add the respect to wait
for the finish of the blood sweat and scalp at least
okay at least anyway let's go to the chart guys and let's understand how we can capitalize on this like
this so first of all if you have multiple accounts
and you notice that the market is giving you this specific condition three no retracement three or
retracement candle directional at opening okay so if you don't have the balance area
and the exit but you have opening of the session and you have one two three okay talking about five
one minute candle but you notice the momentum usually what you can try to do on smaller accounts to get a
crazy list to reward and i did this but i do this only on small account 100 200 300 000
dollar okay is to get two or three attempt to take the home run okay so to take the reversal
this setup here mean reverting it's not convenient to do on account that are the main account and at the
same time it's not having a high risk to high rate okay so this movement that we have today it's better to
play fade to play fade to the top what do i mean that you fade the retracement with absorption of the buyers
back to the direction of the day okay it's already one percent to 1.5 percent down today
till we don't see any solid structure shift we don't go up am i clear guys
okay perfect second of all i want you to use your brain okay so as trader we work with probability so
we work with certainties we work with probabilities okay what does it mean that if if profile framing have
an accuracy of 70 percent okay you cannot burn your account these three times out of ten
that the market goes against you okay because otherwise you know what you do profile framing long
i go long i made a lot of money okay plus five r perfect then another day profile framing i made a lot
of money plus five hour okay then when you have a reversal okay the market continues to go you long
you lose everything how many chicken we have in the chat i know that you have done some one of you have
done it okay like you don't put in your mind the idea that this it's not always if this was always we
don't have the concept of risk i go full margin every day okay what's the problem you need to
understand that your account must be covered because sooner or later sooner or later guys the profile
framing needs to shift it's not an infinite trend and the stop loss that you take when the days shift
and the bias change cannot be as big as the profit that you made the previous day otherwise you have
a skew on the negative side okay and this is destroying your trading account make sense for you
okay now when we go on the chart and we go
wait why it's blocked here
wait a second
can you see deep charts guys
no it closed wait a second up again
should be visible here
one and two
it works okay guys look what i told you okay started the live here we could expect this reversal now
this continuation sorry you go on the profile framing no
look closely the profile framing
give it a little time to load yeah today it's a dump
okay now
what we had what we had we had the market that close directional up okay
already when it comes and it breaks inside inside the value area i
is this telling you that the long bias it's holding or is completely absorbing
it's absorbing otherwise you will have kept this value area low okay
so i know for a fact that even if we open
the new york session with a rejection of the pocket only short directional be honest with me guys
there are some of you that even if they broke even the value area low they continue to try the long
here is it true or no
yeah now you see how many people in the chat now all this price action
below the cash session of the previous two days can be a long or not for the point of view of profile framing
the maximum i can accept is that you try another longer the composite pipe poc but it's a mean reverting
okay and now i want to go here because this is where the money are lost okay
let's go to the previous distribution okay i want you to see
please think with me okay let's think together and let's have a conversation about this
look at the cluster of the aggression of the sellers and look at the amount
300 here 600 contract 335 you see how much they are pushing aggressively okay on the same level the
buyers try to take control we have 105 contracts at the top is this ax absorbed or not completely absorbed
perfect
what we have here another move down aggression aggression look at the buyers attempt fail attempt fail attempt
fail attempt fail they didn't want a single battle
would you consider longing here no look at the opportunity guys that we have today look at the
opportunities you can be confused here absorption and absorption but when you close this candle
do you agree with me that this is a setup okay also now no look at this closing of the candle no
now this one is trying to close below with aggression this setup makes sense okay this setup makes sense
you need to wait that they close below the absorption of the sellers so this break and test this one
it's a continuation setup okay
it's a continuation setup
i'm going to show the settings for the con it's the standard you just apply the template
you just apply the template now it's really easy the settings bogdan you just keep the cache session
okay and the composite is the last three months 90 days so you can set up this also for other platform
of course i look at structure level but the pressure it's more important to me for example now
they tested these absorbed sellers guys what happened what happened they broke or not guys i know that
i want to explain to you but then i cannot help myself i always need to set to give you a setup okay
always need to give you a setup now let's go here let's see what what is happening here again
tap into this is a level that is giving us a clean understanding of a decision one
one and also this one it's a decision level why it's a decision level because you have a cluster of
aggressive of aggressive sellers and a cluster of absorbed buyers okay you know that this movement
can create another squeeze and you will think no but it's impossible we already went down a lot of pips
okay we already went down a lot of pip sticks or what you use it's impossible now look if we manage
to break this one consider that if this one gets broken so we have a closure of the one minute candle
below this one it's a confirmation okay this one is a confirmation and the market will continue to
accelerate look at taka
guys i'm the only retarded that to prepare for you the lesson spend one hour and half to give you the
best experience and didn't make money today the only one
you all made fifteen thousand eight thousand five thousand two thousand
let's wait this is something interesting that you can learn live
oh look at this now this little boy this little boy
decided to buy 74 contract here okay now this is an absorption in run okay what do you mean that you see
the buyers attempting and getting completely absorbed in one second okay completely absorbed in one second
now this one can also be an aggressive entry but i don't like it because we don't have a clean
path we didn't broke the bottom yet so the market can stay here for 15 minutes
probably won't be a day like this for a month unfortunately i know it's not common
but i don't have a day like this for at all this year amazing amazing
now we are not interested okay we are in the middle we are in the middle okay we are in the middle but as
you can see when they go high in the curve so they go they go close to this they show a little bit more
interest as of now we have participation of the buyers trying to absorb okay it's the same level you
see that the buyers are loading at this horizontal level they loaded the total of 130 contract
horizontally and the sellers are loading here so they are engaging in the middle this is not where i want
to engage i want to have a clean path i don't want consolidation guys now if we reach back to this
level what does it mean that these buyers become trapped okay the sellers becomes rewarded so we we
probably have the closure of disorders and we have a squeeze okay this is the probability that we have
again other money victor other money
what does this tell you that sellers are willing to buy to sell sorry at lower prices
and if they are willing to sell at lower prices it will mean they will probably have another follow
through and continuation of the move okay
cool the buying also mean closing position you don't know if it's closing or opening yes but you have
an information okay you have a strong information out of this battle i know that the sellers won and they
reloaded here so what they are dangling me with this one is that they locked the direction now i want to
see how the candle close but they lock the direction
okay and also like you know how much it's useful this continuation gap
do you see what i told you they are reloading and reclaiming confirming back the direction
okay yeah the micro gap it's powerful guys now you see that buyers are starting to engage and now
they have a second cluster this second cluster if recovered by sellers create another acceleration
that send us directly here okay to take profit
today guys is not an easy day i strongly don't advise for you to execute trades okay either you are
the fact that you have a lot of the right experience it's too fast or it's too fast it's too fast
it's too fast also for me to watch the chat and manage
you see how much they listen pedro
Pedro, 1,169.
Guys, I start to think that you don't care at all about the education.
You just want to make money.
Even though there are great opportunities,
today can be a disastrous day for the beginner.
Yes, because they try maybe to fade the levels, no?
Fabio, don't execute the chat.
13 trades today.
Beautiful.
What do you think about this setup that we saw, guys?
Amazing, eh?
Amazing one.
Amazing, amazing one.
Yeah, probably they have another acceleration, guys.
The target is not so long.
But you see, when you understand the pressure dynamic,
you get really smooth entry.
Like, you get really clean, directional.
You are not in the choppy.
Okay?
Even if you enter momentum here with the stop loss above the aggression,
like, you are 1, 2, 3 fast.
Oh, guys, I don't have only, I don't have glass ball.
I have only order flow balls.
And there are days that are difficult also for me.
It's not always easy, of course.
Yeah, we are close.
We are close to the value area low, but in this collapse day, I prefer to join momentum.
Okay.
Now, these buyers are relevant.
Because these buyers are the first one to be rewarded if the candle closes like this.
So, you can close at 1 to 2, 1 to 2.2.
Something like this.
If this candle closes like this, and they don't get accepted,
probably the next candle pushes down.
You see?
Confirmation.
You see how much order flow is powerful, guys?
I'm showing you with multiple setups every week.
What they told you here?
They told, look, we tried.
We got absorbed.
So, either you trail your stop loss below this candle,
so you close at 1 to 1.8 till you make money.
Okay.
Either you decide to take your position out.
If now you are still in the short, you get liquidated here.
If it touch the top of the week.
Otherwise, the sellers reload.
You have exactly the level where the sellers are protecting,
because you have passive order, and you see the fight.
Now I mark the level of the buyers.
You see the fight.
Another attempt.
So, if also them get rejected,
we shoot down to the target directly.
Okay.
I think order flow gives you the confidence to keep the position.
You see?
Double absorption plus...
Guys, how much is beautiful?
How much is beautiful?
Okay.
I have the gut to show you this live every day.
Doing live analysis, not delayed, every day.
Okay.
This one, it's not me.
I'm not...
It's not me that I'm good.
It's that it's subjective.
Okay.
Like, there is not one in the...
There is someone in the chat that will try to go long here.
Based on what I told you.
What I spent time and effort to explain to you.
Okay.
No one will go long here.
It's a suicide.
It's counter trend.
It's counter bias.
Okay.
And we are making sure...
We are just making sure, guys, that we are in the position for...
Either for a full take profit or as much as sellers gives us the confirmation that they want to continue.
Okay.
And here they say...
Look, we absorbed.
Here they say we are willing to sell at lower levels.
Now we have passive liquidity order here.
So there is a buy wall.
There is a buy wall here.
Guys.
Guys, you are trading FTMO.
I am explaining SOS.
Waka's Fabio.
I have already made my investment back 10 times.
Guys, how many of you paid back the $1,000?
One in chat.
From the beginning, eh?
We are only not even the first month of the...
Crazy.
Amazing.
You see also the level that I marked for you.
It said here we have passive liquidity order of the buyers.
Absorb sellers.
And look where we go.
It's data.
It's data, guys.
It's objective data.
There is nothing else.
Nothing else.
Now, what they are doing now?
They are going back to rebalance the gap and the validation level.
Okay.
Which one is the validation level?
Is this white?
I can remove all of this.
They are going back here.
Okay.
Because this is the level from where the sellers won the most important battle previously.
It's possible that we have another opportunity.
Fabio, where can we look for an entry now?
We just saw this short, Davide.
Just saw together this short.
Don't force entry.
We don't have anything now.
If we go here and we see some absorption of the buyers, we have another one.
Luca, where are you?
You are not texting it.
You are making money.
You little Italian bastard.
Fabio, in session like this, do you sometimes think to take longs?
Of course.
Of course, I can think to take longs.
But I need to see a switch in the buyers.
On the smaller account, I can try to take a home run.
Maybe I have not the one-minute chart.
I use the five minutes, the 15 minutes on the most important demand.
But you have to consider that your win rate will be low.
So maybe before taking the $20,000 trade, you lose five times $1,000 trades.
Okay.
And it's part of the game.
It's another approach.
Okay.
So they reached the level again.
They went back to this level.
Now the guy was saying, can we see if we have another setup?
Yes.
Let's remove this previous risk to reward.
And let's do the analysis as the situation we have now.
Where is Luca?
I don't see him in the chart.
He's making money.
He's executing.
Okay.
Now we are incorporating all the volume that we have here.
Perfect.
What do we know?
Guys.
Now, please.
Not even the time to explain.
Do you see the level that we mark?
Do you see the level?
Do you understand that we mark the most important level of the whole area from where they reloaded?
And the bottom, the exact bottom, the continuation phase, the continuation phase, and the level where they reloaded.
Okay.
When they approach this level, you add multiple scenarios.
The first one is that you have an aggression of the buyers and a candle that slides through.
Okay.
The second one is absorption from the buyers.
And the last one is that buyers bring the price here, but sellers reload.
You know how many times I say they reload on the same horizontal level?
So, I don't think it gets easier than this.
I don't think it gets easier than this.
Now, in this kind of setups, okay, the best approach that you can have is working on limits as soon as the candle closes.
So, let's say this candle closes, you take the test, you cover with a relief in stop loss.
Okay.
I didn't have the time to explain.
I was expecting a little bit more of consolidation.
But anyway, I go back to my explanation.
So, we are here in the decision level.
Of course, the target is the same.
Of course, the target is the same if you shorted this movement.
But anyway, we have a distribution where the value area high is full of absorbed buyers.
And you can see from this peak.
So, they punched a wall here.
They punched a wall here.
And they had practically zero results.
Okay.
There was no result of these buyers.
Now, in this case, okay, we also have the situation where the sellers locked the movement.
And from where the sellers locked the movement.
Can you see that the maximum point of aggression of all these areas is this horizontal level?
One in chat.
So, you have buyer's attempt failed.
Seller's attempt already confirmed by the first take profit.
Going back, reloading on the same horizontal level that is also the level where you see the most amount of participation of the sellers.
What can you expect from this?
You can expect the first touch reaction.
That is the one that you can take with a limit order.
And if they manage to go back here, they change the trend.
Okay.
So, if you see again buyers reaching this level and breaking with a full candle, it's useless that you try another short because probably they go up.
What's the second scenario?
That from our area, we continue directly to the red one.
And probably we project also to the round number, the 25,500 for a crazy risk to reward on the short one.
Okay.
This one, if someone managed to take also a little bit late and we managed to break this intermediate and go here, it's a one to five.
The chat works.
Let me refresh.
You can see my live, yes?
No?
Oh, yes, right.
I had to refresh because the chat was not visible for me.
Guys.
Now, be careful here because this is where all the sellers got absorbed.
This is a risk level.
Okay.
This level here, horizontal level here.
If we break this one, we go one and two really fast.
Okay.
And notice that when you break this one, you can see the participation of the aggressive sellers because they just confirmed the movement.
So, you can start to see bubbles back, back, back, back, back, pushing down.
If you scroll above the chat, it gets blocked.
Yeah, if you enter here, but even before you could go break even.
Okay.
Depends on how you enter.
Look at the reaction on the level that I marked for you.
This is the most difficult level for the sellers to break because they already lost the battle here.
You know, I want to share with you this narrative, and I hope that this can stack to your brain.
See, the market has a checkpoint.
Okay.
Sellers try to attack here.
They already lost the battle.
Okay.
If they win this battle, they move to the next one.
The next one is the passive liquidity.
Okay.
And the potential projection.
The sellers are still fighting.
They are not giving up.
The buyers are holding a little bit more.
I expect them to see their action back here.
Okay.
If you have this understanding, you remove from your mind the concept of I need to make 1 to 10,
I need to make 1 to 20, I need to make 1 to 100.
Okay.
You see what happens when the buyers try to take control back again.
Now, if you are in the position, you can cover yourself above this absorption.
So, you can take, for example, 1,000 on 2,000 out of the risk to the market.
Now, I reason in my terms around 10, 15 contracts.
But if you trade less size, this difference, it's 1 to 2,000 dollars.
It's better to have in our pocket, no?
Specifically in a day like this.
Guys, for people that joined this week that are new, am I clear in what I explained?
Is it difficult?
I also created for you, look at this absorption.
I also created for you a section called Neural Pattern Recognition where you can see the best model that I have to execute,
how I use it should be clear for everyone to understand.
Fabio, we need more psychology training.
Today, we do.
Today, we do a little bit of mental models because I see that the people are getting really strong with the model.
Sometimes, they get fucked up by psychology.
And when you have a good model like this, psychology can play a bad role.
Yes, of course, we can go through it.
I just want to let you finish this setup.
Now, if you get consistent every day at marking a reversal area with this precision,
will this be worth the investment that you have done?
So, this sell, this rejection sell, this buy and this buy, okay?
You think yes, no?
It's possible for you to live out of it.
You can make a full-time income trading, okay?
If you are precise.
But you don't need to forget that trading is also about psychology.
So, it's also about when you can say stop.
It's about when you can be happy with what you have done and understand that it's time to detach.
Because you know what's the risk here?
And I think some of you added that when you...
It's so easy to click and make $1,200, $2,000.
You can overtrade.
Specifically, if you are in the overexcited run, okay?
So, another one, another one.
It's short.
Another one, another one.
And then, the part that is the most sad is when you have an amazing day and you give back all the profit, or also more than the profit, back to the market.
How many of you?
You see, guys, they show you that the sellers are being absorbed, but the buyers is not changed.
You understand now when I say it doesn't make sense to try to long a market that, as of now, it can change.
But, as of now, it's telling us.
You see, also a reload here.
Okay.
Also a reload here.
1 to 2, 1 to 3, 1 to 4, consistent.
Not 1 to 20.
1 to 3, 1 to 4, consistent.
Okay.
And they are blocked on the same level.
Probably, if they break, they go directly to the white level that I marked, and they have the first reaction.
Let me mark it precisely for you.
Because round numbers are loaded with contracts.
Okay.
So, now they are validating.
The auction is confirming the short.
They tested back the aggressive trades.
They want to see if they can hold.
Okay.
So, this candle is the decision one.
If they manage to close below, so if this bike handle tests this level, get rejected on the way down, it will not surprise me if we go to test the white one, because it's the level where all the movement started, and here we test.
Okay.
Then rejecting all again after this, and closing below this level.
In this case, this is the most sensitive target that we can have.
Otherwise, it means that this passive liquidity level is really strong.
And if the passive liquidity level is really strong, guys, it makes sense that you work with partials.
So, I'm floating 5,000.
I take 2,500 out here.
The other one, I can let it run, and we see what we can reach.
Now, what the market told us.
They managed to break the white level, the origin of the move?
No.
Now, if they didn't manage to break the white level, it means that the sellers are still active.
So, we have also a sell liquidity level.
Okay.
And it means that now we are playing video games inside this cluster.
This down part is controlled by sellers.
This part is controlled by buyers.
Okay.
So, the buyers are attempting with actual executed order to break this level.
And at the moment, the candle is not closed.
There is no big trades.
But at least you can see that they are really trying their best.
You see?
They are trying their best.
Now, they are making not a full breakout.
Because to make a full breakout, they need to close the candle above the wick.
Because this means that they are strong on the upside.
If this happens, they go back here.
Okay.
To the validation point one.
Let's see how the battle unfolds.
They got absorbed at the top.
Again.
At this cluster.
Best setups for now is this.
The one that we prepared.
Out of all the setups, this one was the best one.
It was really clean.
This one was not a AAA.
It was AA.
Still beautiful.
Now, I think it will present again another short setup.
Okay.
Another short setup.
But we need to wait.
Because if you see this level rejected.
Now, buyers will attempt to go back here.
And they will like to see some absorption.
If we see some absorption, it can get interesting.
I will mark for you the other level.
First absorption.
So, here the buyers are telling you that they push really aggressively on the upside.
And they had the result.
Okay.
Because they are being broken and recovered.
Now, when we know.
Because nothing changed.
Okay.
We know that we have a wall here.
This strong wall.
And if we don't manage to reach the wall.
An interesting area for us to engage again.
Could be the recovery of this movement.
So, showing us that we have failed auction here.
So, they try to break this level.
They get absorbed.
Okay.
This can be interesting.
But, this didn't happen.
They were aggressive.
So, this one is not valid.
We go at the top.
And we see.
Is this level sensitive or not?
As you can see, the level is giving a reaction.
What's the difference between what I told you?
First touch level.
First reaction level.
Why?
Because every time they fill orders.
And you can see that here they fill aggressive orders.
And also absorption.
Because the price got completely absorbed here.
Now, they are managing to break.
Okay.
Yes, of course, we can put J.
Of course, we can put.
If we have another setup, I tell you.
Okay.
Let me put also the speed of day.
Guys, as always, it's not a financial advice.
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
Okay.
Educational purpose.
You should not trade.
You should do gardening.
And stuff like this.
Now, we watch the aggressive orders.
So, they are tapping into the cluster.
And I see that the buyers are not being absorbed anymore.
You notice the buyers push at the bottom.
And they are not absorbed anymore.
Jay.
I got two kids.
They go to good school.
Not cheap.
Of course, Jay.
If we have another setup, I give you.
More than happy to do it.
Okay.
But we cannot force setups.
Only when it's there.
This candle is really important.
Because this candle, it's an initiative auction.
You see the speed of tape.
This one is the potential momentum setup.
Where can you go with this momentum setup?
This one is the first moment where the buyers take control.
This is already a 1, 2, 2.
We can put a 1, 2, 3 and wait for the test.
Okay.
How did we frame this setup?
You see that in this candle, we have a strong speed of tape with a crazy aggression long.
Is it clear for everyone, guys?
One in chat.
On this situation here, what you usually can see is that the buyers get rewarded.
You flip the auction, and I told you, if you watch the session later, I tell you, if this level breaks, we go up.
We get really aggressive on the top, and they reload that aggressive long on the top, you can see here.
Now, the sellers are trying to protect this movement.
Okay.
You see that they are trying to push it back down.
But the buyers are absorbing.
And this is the typical example of a momentum setup.
What's the downside of a momentum setup?
Who can tell me?
What's the only point?
They have a huge win rate.
There is only one downside.
It's not small risk to reward, because 1 to 3 is amazing.
It's difficult to get filled.
Okay.
So, if we got filled with a week here, and it exploded, we would already be risk-free.
Floating 1 to 2.
The problem of the momentum setup, and the reason it's called momentum, is because it's fast.
Okay.
So, but let's see, because maybe it comes back to test.
Let's see, maybe it comes back to test, because now I see that the buyers are getting absorbed here.
So, I can mark this protection level of the sellers.
From here, the sellers seem to be absorbing.
Beautiful template, Carl.
I love it.
This blue.
Beautiful colors.
A flip in the auction is when I see the momentum shifting.
And I see a flip in the auction, Bogdan, with speed of tape plus aggressive orders.
This candle, it's a flip in the auction for me.
It's the first time the buyers get big trades, speed, and direction in one candle.
Is it clear, Bogdan?
No.
It's a concept of orders.
Because the structure can be really fake.
Maybe they do the candle here, and you lose all the move because you wait for structure.
Look how much is beautiful, this one.
They reloaded on the absorption of the sellers.
Amazing.
If it runs too far from your order, would you consider cancelling your limit order if it runs too far from my order?
In this case, yes.
But still, you know, what I want to let you understand is this.
What kind of edge is this?
To know when the auction flip, to know when you can fade reversal.
Cancel.
Amazing.
Now, if they go...
I cancelled the limit order because the market was already pushing high.
But if they go back here in all this area...
We have a long, eh?
Look how much is strong this one.
This one, anyway, it's another setup, eh?
This one here.
This setup here, if you break the top...
Let me put it clearly.
This is another setup.
It's a one to two momentum.
So here.
But you need to have closing candle.
So it's closing candle that needs to close above, okay?
And then you enter.
I mark also the area.
Buyers protecting on the horizontal level.
Guys, you use what you prefer as a platform.
You use what you prefer.
I will never force you to use anything.
What works for you?
Use.
You see it.
You see this intra-gap.
Now, what do they like to do with intra-gap?
What do they like to do?
They like to close it.
Okay.
They close it just now.
And they like to go up the direction.
Okay.
Fortunately, you have the level holding here.
When you break...
You have your confirmation.
Guys, I'm only afraid that I'm going to advance
because we went directly to setups.
Is it clear also for the new people?
One in chat.
Everything I'm explaining is clear also for new people.
Amazing.
Beautiful.
Another confirmation of the speed.
Auction flipping, Arslan.
It's when you have speed of...
Mamma mia, ragazzi.
What a momentum.
It's when you have candle with aggression on it and speed.
Immediately, Pierre.
Rick doing 3,800.
Fabio, you are scamming all market.
And, ragazzi.
Crazy.
Mamma mia.
Luca wake up.
Luca, it's only wake up when you close the trades.
You see?
Before, I call him.
But he say, look.
Wait.
I need to make my 10,000 per day.
Then I can talk in the chat.
7,000.
Guys, you trade heavy, eh?
There are some of you that trade the same contract as me.
To make $7,000 in this movement, you trade really heavy.
Okay.
Almost full take profit.
Plus one.
$6,000 here.
$3,000 Apex account passed.
Changing life.
Nice, guys.
But please, be careful.
Okay.
I don't know if you notice.
But between these two candles, there is a small gap I show you.
There is this small.
And the opening above.
So, you expect them to reload.
Like they did.
And then to shoot another leg up.
See?
They reloaded.
They went down.
Another one.
Look how they shoot.
They close the gap here.
Now they go down.
Reloading again.
And if they close green, they go another run.
Sellers are starting to get interested here.
Okay.
Same.
So, they broke the last gap.
They broke the last gap.
Look how much they went close.
And now they are going back to the origin point.
This one can be, this one can be, if you have an absorption, another execution.
Let me mark this for you from zero.
So, we broke this level from here.
And we have the beginning of the move here with absorption of the buyers, okay?
Of the sellers, sorry.
Now, what we need to do to execute another trade here?
We need to have a big trade absorbed like this on the sell side, okay?
Guys, stop sending profit.
Good job, bud.
Please.
I cannot even trade anymore because I made too much on profit.
Crazy.
Okay.
We have a long on the big trades, okay?
I was watching the chat.
Either you have an aggression, either you have a confirmation.
Now, when this candle close, let's wait for this candle to close.
You have a single candle setup.
This one is a little bit more difficult to understand, but how it works.
Let's say that the candle close here, okay?
You have a stop loss below the body.
Below the body.
And a TP 1 to 2.
Okay.
Now, let's watch where the candle close.
The candle close here.
It's a 1 to 3.65.
This one has a lower win rate, but crazy risk to reward.
Because it's a 1 to 4 really fast if you take the auction.
You only lose this trade if the auction fails.
But if the auction fails, you stop searching for longs.
Usually, on these trades, I like to use the profit I made on the first one.
Okay.
And you know when you go break-even?
You go break-even when the auction is broken.
Okay.
So, when you go here, back to the same level where the sellers try to push aggressively,
you can go break-even.
They are absorbing.
This is not staying good for us.
Sellers are absorbing.
We have an horizontal absorption of the sellers here.
So, we go break-even faster than expected.
Zero.
Okay.
Why we go break-even before?
Because even if buyers are really aggressive, you have here this absorption level that put us in an unnecessary risk.
Now, these sellers are absorbed.
Another good sign.
Aggression of the buyers.
Yes.
I can explain.
This is a single candle big trade setup.
And you can do when the auction is really clear.
So, you add a flip and you have a clean direction.
This was our break-even point.
Okay.
So, in any case, you are x3.
Now, they play the game.
Because now, you can either say, oh, I take out 1 to 2.
It's okay.
Or you play for the 1 to 3.65.
Almost 1 to 4, this one is.
Okay.
So, this depends on you.
This depends on what you prefer.
In terms of risk to reward.
If you want a machine gun, 1 to 2, 1 to 2, 1 to 2, 1 to 2, you take it out at the top.
At the horizontal level.
And you see how much we are precise.
If you want to try the home run and take a big risk to reward, look.
The home run can also go to 1 to 7.
Why to 1 to 7?
Because the next cluster, where they really fighted hard, is this one.
So, if you are risk-free and you want to shoot for the home run, this is the 1 to 7.
Let's watch.
One second, guys.
Look at the result of Claudio.
Guys, these are real execution.
Sometimes you have good mentors, but watch at what people are doing with this.
The buyers are getting weak, unfortunately.
The buyers are getting weak.
They are getting weak on this level.
They managed to try to break out, but they are floating around this level.
Let's see if they can take back control.
No, only using order flow now, Eric.
Only using order flow.
I have two screens open.
And I have one with the chat with you.
And the technical one is this that you are seeing.
Okay.
Break-even on this one.
But you see what's good?
We go break-even not because we don't place entry correctly.
But we go break-even when the price reached the level, but this time the sellers win the battle.
Why this is interesting?
Because now sellers are flipping the auction.
Sellers are flipping the auction.
Okay.
They are really aggressive.
Really, really aggressive.
They reach the level again.
You tired, guys, or we want to try another one?
With the profit of all the trades that we took before.
Another one.
Single candle execution.
Where it closed, we are.
I put it here.
I don't know where it can close.
It's a one, two, three.
If it close here.
It's a one, two, two.
Let's see where the candle close.
Let me do some hyperscalping on the seconds.
There is no big trade here.
Nothing interesting for us.
So, the candle one is closed.
We are inside from the closing of the candle.
It's here.
So, one, two, two.
It's actually.
One, two, two.
Here.
Again, absorption of the buyers.
So, it's free.
It's a good method, guys.
The momentum.
I love trading momentum.
Because you know what's good?
That if you take, if the market reverts, you don't lose anything.
But you need to be fast.
You need to be fast.
Massive day.
A lot of people making profit.
Buyers reloading.
The sellers are really trying.
They almost got the key.
And it's really close.
It's three ticks below.
This absorption says that the sellers are attempting.
And how is the result of the sellers, guys, on this one?
On this candle here.
How is the result of the sellers?
Not good.
So, the setup can still go.
And they took us out.
Break-even.
You can do this game till the market continue to tell you.
See why this level.
Well, I marked this before it started to unfold.
And why this level.
It's clear now to you.
Because we are in compression.
And being fast at putting, okay, putting to take profit is the reason that gives you a lot of positive days.
This is the reason.
Because to do home run once, one day out of 10, it's easier.
Let's see here how it goes.
Buyers still recovering.
Now, what is unfolding here?
An attempt from the buyers to push the price higher.
This one, you want to do some hyperscalping, guys.
You want to see when I get crazy what I do.
So, I need to lower the settings to 30.
To take the momentum run up.
Okay.
What happened here?
We had an absorption.
Complete absorption of the sellers.
So, we have a test of this level.
On the 15th seconds.
This one is not for beginners.
For a 1, 2, 3.
This one works amazingly.
When you have a momentum setup in play.
Okay.
That is in the same direction.
The break-even point is really fast, guys.
Okay.
The break-even point is here.
Because this is the most risky level for the buyers to get absorbed.
Okay.
We are sustained from this range.
From this failed auction.
So, it can unfold pretty nicely.
Let's see how it goes.
Please don't execute.
This one is to show you a little bit of hyperscalping.
How it works.
Okay.
So, this is the level that we marked.
They just touched it.
Let's see if this level holds.
Or if sellers try to break.
Sellers are getting super aggressive, guys.
Super aggressive.
In the middle of the range.
They try to touch again this level.
Yeah.
I wanted to show you some hyperscalping.
But this one is more difficult.
They took us out.
This is the first stop loss.
Minus R on this one.
Now, what you can do is you can continue to trade the fade.
So, the continuation long.
Till they have a long bias.
Yes.
I take ashwagandha.
It's one of the best supplements for cortisol control.
We are still buyers in control.
Still buyers in control.
Wait one second.
That's it marked for me also.
The areas that I don't care about.
We need to go back to 60.
And I was explaining to you.
Look here.
So, momentum candle.
They decide that this area gets broken.
Okay.
Perfect.
The buyers take control.
Now, in this area, all this range is sustained by who?
By this absorption level.
This level is the one sustaining all the long.
I took a little bit more to start.
I tried to take from the 15 seconds this movement for a 1 to 5, 1 to 10.
Why this is nice?
Because even if it's more difficult to take the last move down of the 15 second, when you
take the last move down of the 15 second in line with a structure that is on the higher
time frame, you can get crazy risk to reward.
Okay.
You can get really crazy risk to reward.
Let's see when they go out of this.
Cluster 1.
Cluster 2.
You know what's good about volume?
That volume also tells you when there is not any more speed.
You see, action, action, action.
We took a lot of take profit.
Dead market.
And you remember in the beginning of the session when I told you, usually we have a huge explosion
and then chop, chop, chop, chop, chop these days.
This is not, this is not so rare to happen.
They will probably go to say hello to these friends again.
I cannot say if buyers or sellers are accumulating because they are both being absorbed.
So also the CVD now can give me an insight, but it's still an insight that is not followed
by price.
So it's only subjective, you know.
I can try to build a bias.
You see, it's correct the frame that I gave you also on hyperscalping.
Because we are long.
But what happens here that all this delta pressure long, for now, it's being absorbed by the sellers.
For now.
CVD is really easy to use, Eric.
It's a summary for pressure.
Yeah, of course we can do it again.
Like we did last week.
In a calm market where I can also manage the chart, we can trade.
Yes, it's not a problem.
I can show you how I manage and do everything.
Now, this one is not so bad, price action.
Why is it not so bad?
Because I have a really clean and defined ranges.
So what does this mean is that when you broke, you break out of here.
The movement, this is what I was trying to explain.
In the 15th second, when you have a breakout, you do a huge risk to reward, okay?
Because if they manage to break, you have a really tight stop loss.
Because you are loaded with heavy contracts.
So what I was trying to say, on the 15th second, maybe you take three stop loss of 1,000, but the trade that you make is 10 to 20,000.
Make sense?
Just, it's not the main operational method because the win rate is lower.
If you have a look here, they bought at the top, they bought at the top, and you can see that still on the same level, the 25,706, the sellers step in always, always keeping them in the range.
But this one, it's for trend-following trades, it's really bad price action, guys.
Look at Tobias, guys.
$18,000.
I'm not an expert in PropFerm and Apex, guys.
But I know for a fact that they have really tight rules.
So if you can build your profit like this for a day, how much does it cost a challenge?
I don't know how much it costs.
How much does it cost a challenge?
I think with $200, $300, you take it, right?
$39.
Okay.
Tobias, is this amount something you can withdraw?
This $18,000, if it's funded, you can withdraw the full amount if you are live.
I don't know, when you go live, look at what they did.
Amazing.
Yeah, if it's live, you can withdraw, no?
$3,500.
Let's consider even less.
Let's consider that you can withdraw $350.
Based on what you pay in the beginning, it's a 10x ROI.
It's fucking difficult to do in business, 10x.
Guys, the view was correct.
Our analysis was perfect and the bias is correct.
They are managing to break it.
And you can see that the big trades get higher.
So, the pressure is still building.
You see?
The pressure is still building.
They are continuing to confirm the breakout.
So, now, probably, after all this absorption,
we will have another nice momentum candle.
Probably, we can...
I will consider this top.
And I will consider this bottom of the range.
I would like to see if they manage to break.
Yes, of course.
Of course, you can share.
You just went out of the consolidation,
but you see that they continue to absorb.
Okay.
So, usually, you have a squeeze
when you break out of the consolidation.
And they are managing to do it.
Okay.
You see?
They are pumping at higher prices.
So, it means that still big trades
are entering at aggressive higher prices.
This means that they want to go up.
Okay.
And now, when all these sellers
start to close position,
you see that.
Exactly this.
Kaidar took another $14,000.
This is interactive brokers.
I can recognize.
Good job.
It's a real account.
Yeah.
Now, we go to the psychology guide.
I don't think you are in a rush.
No.
You can stay a little bit.
What is this?
Candle closing red and this green.
Would you consider a long?
If the candle close red inside here,
I will be fucking scared too long.
I was waiting for a full breakout,
but it didn't.
They are trying again.
If they do it,
if they break the top of this,
you have a momentum setup.
I want to choose momentum setup,
but they need to break the top.
When I say break the top,
I mean it's body.
You see, they failed.
You see how much it's important
to see the result,
not only the effort.
Not only the effort.
They managed to try.
They didn't even touch at the top
because the sellers absorbed everything.
How you profit from that?
From this, you cannot.
You are not even into a trade.
They are back in the range.
Outside the range,
back in the range.
Just need to wait.
They are trying back again
and being absorbed.
Guys, you know that
from the path of list resistance,
it seems that they are
switching the buyers here.
It seems to me...
So one, two,
they break back inside.
This one,
it's a crazy absorption
of the buyers.
On this one,
if they close back inside here,
I will not
ignore
a rebalance setup.
I will not ignore
I marked this level
because this is the level
where if they close full candles,
so the candle close,
close inside,
so the result is coherent
with the volume,
it's an opportunity,
an attempt from the sellers
to go down.
Because all these absorptions
needs to pay out, no?
All these absorptions
needs to pay out.
So if they manage
to break the top
for break, guys,
I mean cleaning all this week.
Okay, so they need to clean
all this week.
We capitalize on the way down.
If they break the top
here,
that I'm not so convinced
that they will do.
I think they will have
another absorption
at the top.
We have a momentum long.
I cannot see your hamlet.
You don't have position open,
right?
Yeah, it seems
an absorption
of the buyers, guys.
This one is still valid,
but they need to close,
you see,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five weeks.
They need to clean.
They need to close
full candle
on the short side.
No position.
It doesn't make sense.
They are still chopping.
Let me zoom in.
If it close here,
if it breaks this area,
no,
I take the limit.
You see another absorption
at the top.
If it close like this,
if it close like this,
we have a setup.
Let's see if it close.
Wait for the close.
The stop loss
goes below
the absorption
and it's a one
to two again.
This one is confirmed.
Why it's confirmed?
Because we have
absorption of the sellers,
absorbed sellers again
on these three levels,
so we can expect
the sellers
to be absorbed
and the buyers
to take control
of the squeeze
and we will go break even
when we see
that all this level is clear.
Okay,
so when we have a catalyst.
Oh,
the sellers
don't leave position
to the market.
They are super aggressive.
Look,
no one is taking control.
There is a huge fight here.
There is no momentum unfolding.
They are fighting.
Look at this white level
that I marked for you.
Look how they are fighting here.
It's crazy.
Sellers taking back control.
This one is a stop, guys.
And on this one,
on this one,
you see the fade momentum
when you break.
This candle,
what is telling you,
chat?
Buyers aggressive at the top.
Sellers absorb at the bottom.
This candle,
breaking a range,
what is telling you?
From an order flow perspective,
we tried,
we got absorbed.
We tried,
we got rewarded.
And this one,
what was?
Was the analysis correct
or no, guys?
Look at this.
What was this?
This one,
if they manage
to absorb this
and go up,
it's a fake out.
It's when the market
dance around areas
and goes in the direction.
So in the journal,
you need always
to mark
that there is a price
to pay for precision.
And the price
to pay for precision
is that sometimes
you will have
correct bias,
but you take stop loss
not because
the analysis
is incorrect,
but because
the stop loss
is too tight.
Yeah,
they are still fighting.
No one still won.
I think this is
the most interesting area
after the opening,
and this is the reason
I ask you,
it's already one hour
and a half of life,
but please,
you are not bored,
right?
So we update the top,
we update the bottom,
and this is our new area.
We want to mark
all this
in a specific color.
And this one, guys,
is the battle.
This is all the battle
that's happening.
The absorption of B4,
the aggression
of the sellers,
now the market
is really chopping out.
The direction
that breaks
is the direction
that it takes.
means,
let's think about
a change of blue,
all the little
Dzint.
Next day,
it gives back
a green,
and this place
will not really
come in.
If there's aเข
to the power
that means
without the
drop-tiquette closed.
If there's a
saiyah
at the bottom,
there's another
There's another
there left
that is
going in.
That the
well there's
there.
The
for a
long
They tap the low borders of the buyer's protection level and I managed to protect it again.
To limit the loss for the day, Guilherme, you can put a maximum number of execution and a cap on the loss.
Cap on the profit doesn't work so good, cap on the loss, yes.
After this mess we will have a huge movement. We already had a huge movement.
But yes, I think after this here, the market will move.
Look at the difference of the option.
And it gave us an amazing price action, an amazing long here and then it started to chop out.
They are trying to break on the downside.
Guys, look at this absorption. Every time it goes back inside.
It seems that the sellers are taking control. Let's see if they close like this.
Yes. Sellers took control.
This candle closed down. The buyers got absorbed.
Imagine now they go back inside and they continue.
For another hour.
Now, this condition here, this condition here, it's the market killer of the scalper.
Not because you lose money.
Because you take one take profit, one break even, one break even.
One stop loss, one break even, one take profit.
You are still around the break even line.
You know what's the problem?
That if you open heavy like me, 20 contracts, 18, you pay a huge amount of commission.
You pay 5 or 10 thousand commission to the broker. Dollars.
This is the problem.
So now what can we see?
We can see that the buyers attempted to break and reload on the way up on this candle.
They failed, but also the sellers tried to break on this way up and they failed.
Still nothing exciting.
Still going back in the range, break out in the range, going back in the range.
You know what, Andrea?
You need always to make a consideration based on protection, no?
I come from a bad trauma.
I don't know if some of you know, but I was one of the top ranked scalper in FTX.
Crypto.
And it was like regulated.
It was supported by the SEC.
They did all the routine check.
I got invited in Abu Dhabi and they disappeared.
Okay.
They disappeared.
So as of now, I prioritize more than commission, the regulation and the proof of funds and the insurance on the funds.
Wait one second, guys, because I cannot see the chart.
But they say that they will send it back again.
But I don't know, Tony.
I don't believe in fairy tales.
It's already years that is going on, but I still didn't receive anything.
Yeah, I know there is a procedure and I did it, but didn't receive anything.
Yeah.
It's not the best on commission side.
Now we are trying to deal with other solution because when you have an influence, you can also deal for better commission rates.
And beautiful, guys.
Look what it's unfolding.
It's clear to you now what happened here.
Absorption of the buyers.
Three rejections outside of the range.
Now here we have more confirmation and clarity that they rejected the area and they want to take a direction short.
Now we are trying to deal with other solutions because when you have an influence, you can also deal for better commission rates.
And beautiful, guys.
Look what it's unfolding.
It's clear to you now what happened here.
Absorption of the buyers.
Three rejections outside of the range.
Now here we have more confirmation and clarity that they rejected the area and they want to take a direction short.
Here it's more clear.
Sellers rewarded.
The buyers.
Now the buyers you see are attempting again.
And this one is really similar.
You remember I marked this horizontal level and they show you here.
So for the actual price action that I reply, it can go back to consolidation because this is the nature of the market now.
But when you have directional movements like this, usually they reload on the absorption.
Okay.
So one, two, and then you have another slice down.
So in this case, one, two, and then you have another slice down.
Okay.
They look at another contract.
Now another 136 contract.
Now in this condition here, they are fighting between this absorption of the buyers.
Here.
And this big trade of the buyers, the aggression.
The sellers seem to nominate.
What a beautiful one.
Guys, I think the volatility will kick back when they clean the level.
Okay.
When they clean the level, all the accumulation of the phase gets cleaned.
And then it's the option flow.
It's really long.
It takes at least 10 or 20 hours of full education to understand.
This is not the topic and we are using order flow.
I will come out with free content on YouTube for the option flow.
Because I think it's another piece of the puzzle.
But as of now, I'm only using order flow.
Okay.
I'm only using order flow now.
But I think it's good to understand.
Specifically today.
Could that give you some insight?
Maybe if you have more probability to go short.
I didn't even watch.
Yeah.
There was one guy.
Look at what a beautiful movement.
There was one guy that asked me for advice to put tax to zero.
Because I don't know if you know.
But in UAE, there is capital gain at 0%.
And you have also, if you structure it properly, you can go to 9% maximum tax on the company.
But also 0% to company.
So you can have 0% on the personal, on the capital gain and on the company.
That's a big advantage.
So there was one guy asking me, Fabio, can you give me some advice?
Can you introduce to the lawyers?
I want to relocate to UAE, to Abu Dhabi.
Because this place is letting you scale really, really fast, guys.
If you make money, keeping 100% of what you make, it's compounding heavy in years.
Let's see how this unfolds.
They went back to test the absorbed buyers.
Back to the initial absorption level.
What a boring price action now, guys.
One directional move, choppy.
Choppy, one directional move.
Directional move, absorption.
That's getting really boring.
Yes, now we do psychology.
I'm not running, Roy.
I like to spend time with the community.
So now we go on the psychology.
I was just replying more casual questions.
Now we go on mindset models.
Let's just see.
I'm really curious to see.
Now it's getting personal.
I want to see who in this battle.
Because as of now, for example, they re-break out.
They reloaded on this one.
It seems that they want to break the full range.
I'm really curious to see what they do.
Need set company, but not sure how to do it with no scam.
Don't worry.
Contact.
I can introduce people that know how to do it.
They are professional and they make sure that you don't get any fines because Dubai is getting really strong on the fine side.
Nice, Robin.
No, the market data, Tony, you always need to buy.
It can be CME group.
It can be, if you, for example, TradingView provides CME group data.
That is the basic, basic one.
Or you can have proper data feed like DixFeed, the Rhythmic, CQG, level one, level two.
Now, level one is enough.
Now, you know what will be the comedy?
If they break out, print a week and go back inside again.
This will be the comedy.
I'm really happy that we managed to see these moments in the live session because it's super important that you don't get used.
Because you know what is the risk?
That we only get this market condition.
Okay.
One, take profit.
Two, take profit.
Momentum, take profit here.
And you say, ah, when I'm in live with Fabio, I take three or four, take profit.
He never takes stop loss.
Okay.
What this can create in your brain is the expectation to avoid loss.
That is impossible.
So this is still part of the business.
Losing is part of the business.
Trying again to be aggressive.
There is a guy saying it's a fake out.
I don't know.
It seems that it's a clean breakout, a clean directional breakout.
Trade station, CME market data.
They clean.
Finally, they clean the area.
Oh, now we can go to psychology.
So it was a buy breakout.
Let me mark one second the levels.
So the next station is here.
On this aggressive side.
The reload level is this one.
Oh, now it's starting to move.
You see, in two candles, he did the full range.
In two candles, he did the full range.
One and two.
Support levels.
One.
To be honest, we have also one here that is really powerful.
Okay.
Now it's getting a little bit more interesting, the situation.
Now let's go to market models while we watch the price unfolding.
Tom, I don't understand how to capitalize on that without getting stopped out.
This one, I didn't even capitalize on this one.
This choppy and this movement, it was so aggressive.
And more than this, not printing anything on the speed of tape so that I will not even know how to capitalize.
That's the reason I didn't tell you anything on this one.
Okay.
Just this condition here for me, it's not worth to trade.
So don't worry, it's not your problem, Tom.
I was just marking level.
I was not giving any setup or charting or stuff like this.
Okay.
So now let's go on the mindset model and mindset framing that we can have for this profession.
The first thing that you need to do is that it's way easier to trade with profit than to trade with sacrifice capital.
What do I mean?
That it's an exponential effect.
Okay.
The first years where I was still breakeven or losing a little bit with trading for me was super crazy.
Because every time I risk $1, okay, not 1000, but $1, it's $1 that I earn by selling my time as a freelancer.
Okay.
And this one, it's really heavy on the psychology side because you sit at the laptop.
And when you take a stop loss, you always make a comparison that you burn hours of your life.
Maybe for a lot of you that are already wealthy, this community is full of entrepreneurs.
There are three hedge fund managers.
There are strong people.
Okay.
But for people starting, for people that are young, it's a huge effort.
So the advice that I can give you is that if specifically, if you work with personal capital, the best approach that you can have is mine.
So you build profit for the day, you build profit for the day, and you increase the sides when you have enough profit.
Okay.
Axe.
Fabio, three years ago, sold from me, 21 million in crypto.
All my work of years in crypto.
Crazy.
FTX.
Crazy Axe.
So from the mindset side, we always need to frame in our mindset that you can have.
We have a maximum fixed loss for the day, a maximum fixed loss for the month that we stop, that it's our budget.
Consider this like a family budget, but used for trading.
Okay.
So in trading, you have a risk budget for the day and for the month.
You treat your personal capital like if you are trading a prop firm.
Okay.
And when you start from this point, you already put trading in a less risky position because you can look at the reaction of the level.
Sorry guys, but I wanted to show you how they reload on the closer of the selling side.
These are all the sell order closing and creating this drift.
And when you are in a mindset that comes from years of misunderstanding concept and years of fake guru, there is also the disbelief in the strategy.
Okay.
Now, how many of you guys didn't came here as the first content and course one in chat?
So they did something else that didn't work up for them.
Okay.
So maybe you study from any other educator.
And on average, how much did you spend in all your trading life?
On average, 5,000, 10,000 in education, 40,000 to 2,000.
Look at the amount of people.
Okay.
60,000, 30,000, 4,000, 50,000, 50,000, 10,000.
But it's a cumulative amount in the chart of some millions.
Okay.
You spend cumulatively 2 million, 3 million, 4 million total.
All the community.
Now, the point what is, is that we think that the monetary value, it's always anchored to the value of the educator.
Okay.
And this is wrong.
And you know what's the trauma that it creates to the industry and why this industry is traumatized?
To the point that when I was trading, okay, there are people that cannot believe that someone trades live and it's profitable to the point that they think the account is demo.
There are people saying, you are trading a demo in interactive.
So, I had to show in the live that we did on Bloodswell Scalps that I execute and it's directly reflected to interactive and it's the same account.
Okay.
But I start to think and I say, but you see, why people are so traumatized in the industry?
And they came up to a fact that is the amount they spend in trading and the amount of money they lost because there is no other way to be a traumatized industry like this.
People spend money in education and they give also back money to the broker.
So, people are like really traumatized on this.
Okay.
Now, what this create in the mind of the traders?
This create a strong disbelief, not only in the trader itself, but in the strategy that he teach.
That's the reason I think that the only way to change this industry is doing something live.
Okay.
So, someone needs to take the risk and someone needs to go to people, not by preaching, but by showing them at open market what they can do.
This is the only way, guys.
Okay.
And from the psychology point of view, this creates in them a guide.
This creates in them someone that show live when there are losses, live when we take stop loss, live when we take break even, when we manage position together.
We go on everything together.
Okay.
And this one change the neural paths.
And people don't believe in this stuff.
This is the psychology bullshit.
No, this is important.
Okay.
And this is important to the point that I created a dedicated section.
And I created a dedicated section for this based on how psychology, okay, of trading can install a new program based on executional models.
Okay.
So, in the neural side area, this one, it's a squeeze setup.
In the neural side area, this is an absorption of the buyers and the lock-in.
And this is the reason we saw this short move.
This one, it's an horizontal level with a reload of the contracts.
Okay.
And when we go through this, you reinforce, like, you know, for the machine learning, it's called reinforcement learning.
For animals, it's confirmation bias, no?
So, when the dog does something good, then you pet him.
You give him a threat.
This is not something stupid.
Also for traders.
Why is it not something stupid?
Because you get confidence.
Okay.
You get confidence with what you are executing.
You get confidence with what you are trading.
And this point builds the account like nothing else.
Okay.
I cannot promise you that you will get profitable because I will be really bold and I will be a liar because I don't have the power to be with you every day.
But I can promise you something that is worth way more.
I can promise you that the market has reaction points that can be predicted.
Okay.
And that the order flow is the alphabet that makes this language understandable for us humans.
Look at this reload, the level.
Market is doing and I'm explaining.
And what I want you to do to remove the fear in this is participate in the live.
And even if it's only with the simulation account, execute side by side.
Okay.
And every day to spend five minutes in the medal award section because I didn't pay anyone.
I leave the review open.
I don't kick anyone that leaves a bad review.
I let you express in the chat.
Okay.
And when you see that people genuinely support the community and genuinely share 30, 40, 100 execution in two weeks.
This let you understand that they start to feel confident.
Okay.
And they start to feel confident, not because my method is the best, but because they see results in their daily trading activity.
And they close this mindset part with one condition.
Look at what amazing explosion is coming out now.
I close this part with one condition.
Okay.
When you spend years with people that say execute this, this, and this, take the medication, take the order block, take the moving average 50 and 200, you were blaming yourself.
You were blaming yourself, not because you are stupid, but because the model don't work.
Because we need to all agree on one stuff, one in chat, that you can have the strongest psychology in the world.
But if who is teaching you is not making money out of trading, you will not be profitable.
If you have a recipe and the ingredients of the cake are worthless.
Okay.
It will not come a good cake.
It will come something disgusting.
And you cannot blame the chef because he follow all the protocols on it.
Okay.
And this is what we are building together, guys.
Now, the market decided to unlock.
Amazing.
Now, just, I want to steal from you other 15 minutes, because I want to go through the neural pattern and explain one by one to you, so you can practice.
Today was an amazing session.
Unfortunately, we took two stop-loss in the closing range, in this choppy, but it's part of the game.
Okay.
We share together.
We laugh together.
And we see.
The best executive...
This one was crazy, guys.
Now, I wanted to make the guy happy for the mindset part, but this one...
The guy asked me, how can I capitalize?
On this one, you can.
If there is also the speed of tape, it's a masterpiece.
It's empty.
Oh, they went to sleep here.
Speed of tape went to sleep.
Amazing.
Now, let's go.
I remove this screen and I want to give you the secondary screen with something related to neural part.
Capitalized.
Amazing.
Give me one second, because I need to open this for you.
I don't remember where I have the file, I should have it here.
Maybe it's on the other...
Wait a second, guys.
I'm sure it's getting back.
Before I follow Fabio, I used to punish myself after stop loss by pulling weeds out of my yard.
Let's see.
Wait a second.
I think I have here the full file.
Yes, it should be here.
Now I show you.
One, two, three.
Let's share screen.
This is what I put for you in the section.
It's not visible.
Is it visible, guys?
I try it again.
Check now.
One, perfect.
Okay.
So this one is the summary of the model, and this one was created by the Italian team.
There is Luca, who is mainly active on the trading space and content, and there is Andrea,
who is helping us in the content production.
They are really good guys.
And this one was what we were watching the other time, no?
The importance of the delta profile on the rejection level.
Okay.
The low volume node that is giving you the possibility to capitalize.
And these are all the execution patterns.
Let's see them together.
Okay.
Now, the first one is when you are in a range.
You have an absorption of the sellers and a clean direction of the buyers.
This one is the usual candle that we saw before.
So high speed of tape, a lot of big trades, and it will be amazing to see also an absorption.
Is it clear?
One in chat.
Here you have everything.
Okay.
Then when they reload here, okay, you see an absorption of the sellers.
So they are giving you an insight of clean direction, sellers fading, and you have an asymmetrical risk to reward because you can cover below the previous absorption.
Okay.
This is one setup that we executed today, I think, two times.
And we executed during all the blood and swenna scalps at least 10 times.
Now, going on, this one, it's another example.
And you remember, guys, I think it was the second lesson that we saw three or four setups that went one to three or one to five exactly like this.
So you have before an absorption, then you have a confirmation of the aggressive buyers, and you cover below the initial absorption.
This one is an amazing, amazing execution pattern.
Okay.
And it's one of those that we use on the one minute.
Then, going on, we have a squeeze.
A squeeze is amazing because it's fast, and usually you see absorption.
Okay.
Look at this.
You see absorption.
And then, after all this absorption of the sellers, what happens?
You have a move that is aggressive on the upside, absorb, absorb, absorb, this buyer, absorb, absorb, absorb, absorb, absorb, and then, bam!
Okay.
It's the same.
It's not necessary to make double the example because for the sell side, it's the same with different colors.
Okay.
Yeah, you can enter on the retest.
You can enter on the retest.
Okay.
This one, it's when you have also activity.
This one is in the opening usually.
Activity of big orders.
So, you have all this aggression, and then you have an absorption here, and this is your entry.
Okay.
The stop loss usually goes below the candle that created the aggression move.
Then, going on, we have the outside of the balance.
You see fade, fade, fade, close of the candle, aggression.
Okay.
And you have the single candle set up.
So, closing here, one to two, stop loss below the candle if you want to go momentum, or if you want to do ping pong from value area low to value area high, you take the absorption level.
Okay.
You enter here, stop loss below here, and you go to the other side.
And this is a one to three, one to four usually.
Okay.
They are already in the platform, guys.
The section is neural pattern recognition.
I share with you everything.
Everything is shared with you.
How much they are aggressive, guys.
Buyers are heavy today.
Really heavy.
We can take trade short here.
Here?
Why you should take a short here?
They are...
No, not today.
Not today, Roy.
Buyers are strong from the moment.
Ah, more than the rest.
Is this candle working or not?
Did they flip the auction or not?
This works so well.
This works so well at understanding when the auction is changing.
And look at this.
If we go back, okay, and we go at the beginning of the session, the opening, and we put our speed of tape here.
Okay?
We go here.
Guys, it's not rocket science.
Okay?
It's not rocket science.
Which candle is the highest pin that we have here?
It's this one.
Okay?
This candle is a pin.
It means that all the speed of the buyers had zero result.
Is it visible also from big trades that the buyers got kicked in the face?
Yes or no?
No.
That they got completely absorbed, guys.
So what this week is telling you is that they tried really their best to add orders fast.
But they got completely absorbed.
Okay?
And what the market is telling next?
That they tried again.
Adding short, adding long fast.
But the market don't care.
You have absorbed buyers at the top.
Confirmed sellers in the body of the candle.
Where do you want to go?
Okay.
Now, the stop loss will be huge on this one.
I would more like to consider this absorption of the auction of the sellers in place.
Take a short.
Or try to take a test of the momentum, but they didn't do.
One beautiful setup was this one.
Solved.
Okay.
The problem what is?
That the stop loss is really large.
Because the next cluster of aggression is this one.
So it's not the best risk to reward.
It's a 1 to 3 maybe.
1 to 2.
Maximum 1 to 3 maybe.
No.
Sorry.
It's a huge risk to reward.
Anyway.
Not all this session pay out like this.
Okay.
You can take your position out.
Wait.
This is the most beautiful in the sell auction.
Can you, in the chat, understand why this, guys?
Can you explain to me why this?
We went through this setup together.
All this aggression cluster.
The buyers attempting to break.
Getting absorbed.
And there is Jose took the trade.
Took that one.
They reload.
Amazing.
Amazing, guys.
Setup.
No brainer.
A lot of you took it.
Guys.
Two hours together.
I only ask you one stuff.
Okay.
Only ask you one stuff.
Go in the medal awards.
And share.
Okay.
Your process.
Share.
Your success.
In which way this community is improving you.
And put results.
Put results of what you are doing.
Okay.
Now.
Between this afternoon.
It depends on how much it takes for the support team to create it.
But it's more probable that we will have before the New York session of tomorrow.
the live chat with people inside professionals.
I will let anyone talk.
Put a moderator inside.
Please.
Don't spam.
Don't put link to external sources.
I have a few rules.
Don't spam.
Don't put link to external sources.
And if you are starting.
Don't overload the section.
Okay.
Because this section is not for beginners.
This section is for professional.
It's a war room.
Okay.
For people that wants to check.
Confront with other people.
Check.
I can improve here.
I can improve there.
I will make another section.
That will be called setups review.
Where you can put your setups.
And other people of the community can say.
You know what error you do.
You put your stop loss too high.
You put your stop loss too low.
You enter too early.
You keep your trades for too much.
I have a 70% with rate.
Follow what I do.
And you will improve.
Okay.
Everyone will join the battlefield.
Everyone.
Okay.
Just I ask you to be smart.
I don't think I need to restrict the community.
I think I have smart people.
Okay.
On the battleground.
If you are not profitable in the learning space.
Don't text.
Because you confuse other people.
Okay.
Amazing guys.
Love you all.
Have an amazing day.
And see you next week.
So.
Thank you.
Now.
Have a great day.
Thank you.